qu'est-ce que c'est
toi
on affronte le pire maléfice que le
monde est connu
l'assassine les nôtres ça ne ressemble à
rien de ce qu'on connaît
qu'est-ce qui veut notre mort cette fois
tu nous entoure
sa magie est d'un tout autre niveau
sans plus fort
comment on va les battre
je sais quoi faire
je peux poser 5 questions à un mort
après quoi il rumeur
je prononce mal peut-être
beurk formidable
tu as été tué à la bataille super encore
quatre questions c'est ça non non
elle comptait cette question
s'il te plaît tu ne réponds que quand je
t'interroge ok pourquoi tu as dit ok à
la fin de ta phrase j'ai pas dit OK
magnifique où elle appelle